so here i am
hard at work i'm a computer
i'm supposed to be at work
just created a brand new channel now
i've talked about this with my
subscribers before
um but i do little clips from our live
videos and i think they clutch up the
channel a little bit but some people
prefer to watch the live videos and
little short chunks so i've created
psytrek clips there's a link in the
description you can go and subscribe
immediately
um i will also though not just be
recycling and making bike-sized chunks
of the live videos
on that channel i'm also going to do
some little
short ranty videos whenever i watch a
new episode of something or just have
something i want to vent
so
get over there please subscribe let's
see how quickly we can get to a thousand
subscribers
um and as always guys
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe with the bell
notification blah blah blah
please get over though to sidetrack
clips subscribe there more importantly
thanks very much guys and as always
please stay safe
[Music]